the moscow-based web security firm
kaspersky lab says there's been a sharp
rise in the illegal supply of fake
covered vaccination certificates on the
dark net according to them buyers who
pay around 300 can choose the country of
vaccination and also the manufacturer
whether it be astrazeneca pfizer johnson
johnson or modern
we've seen
this market
developed a lot during spring
at the same time when we have uh seen
uh different cyber criminals trying to
sell vaccines uh and vaccine
certificates as well
so for now uh we just see the new wave
talking about the scammers
so these are just people who have
nothing
and they are just going online
in some underground forums and markets
and saying i will sell you anything you
want uh including certificates including
vaccination noses whatever and they are
just trying to convince people to give
them money and uh there is like not a
lot of ways to track them physically
because there are exception
payments and cryptocurrencies and
there they're
using private chats for communications
well the amount of dark net sellers does
continue to rise across the globe and it
can be difficult too to track them as
they are being paid in cryptocurrency
kaspersky lab says scammers are always
on the lookout for an easy target and
that we should stay vigilant
the main thing that we are highlighting
in this research is that
there is no way to check whether those
sub-criminals are just scammers who are
trying to
take money from
from the victims and give nothing back
or they're actually having some way to
send these kind of certificates doing
that
puts users under risk we should remember
these kind of scammers and cyber
criminals whatever they're always trying
to take advantage of the current
situation in the world
and they are always trying to steal or
to get money from victims so that's our
let's say duty just to give a heads up
for the general public and say hey there
is something going on around please be
aware of that and
be secure
you